Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today is going to be all about simulating
virtual bunnies. What kinds of bunnies?
Bunnies in an hourglass with granular
material, bunnies in a mixing drum,
bunnies that disappear, we’ll
try to fix this one too.
So, what was all this footage? Well, this is
a followup work to the amazing Monolith paper.
What is Monolith? It is a technique that helps
fixing commonly occurring two-way coupling issues
in physics simulations. Okay, that sounds great,
but what does two-way coupling mean? It means that
here, the boxes are allowed to move the smoke,
and the added two-way coupling part means that
now, the smoke is also allowed to blow away
the boxes. This previous work makes
can simulate these phenomena properly.
It also makes sure that when thrown at the
wall, things stick correctly, and a ton of
other goodies too. So, this previous method shows
a lot of strength. Now, I hear you asking, Károly,
can this get even better? And the answer is yes,
yes it can! That’s exactly why we are here today.
This new paper improves this
technique to work better in cases
where we have a lot of friction. For instance,
it can simulate how some of these tiny bunnies
get squeezed through the hourglass, and get
showered by this sand-like granular material.
It can also simulate how some of them remain stuck
up there because of the frictional contact. Good.
Now, have a look at this, with this one, with
an earlier technique, we start with one bunny,
and we end up with….wait a minute. That
volume is not one bunny amount of volume.
This is what we call the volume dissipation
problem. I wonder if we can get our bunny back
with the new technique. What do you think? Well,
let’s see…one bunny goes in, friction happens,
and…yes! One bunny amount of volume comes out of
the simulation. Then, we a bunch of them into a
mixing drum in the next experiment where their
tormenting shall continue. This is also a very
challenging scene because we have over 70 thousand
particles, rubbing against each other. And,
just look at that. The new technique is so robust
that there are no issues whatsoever. Loving it!
So, what is all this simulation math good for?
Well, for instance, it helps us set up a scene
where we get a great deal of artistic freedom. For
instance, we can put this glass container with the
water between two walls, and, look carefully! Yes,
we apply a little leftward force to this wall.
And, since this technique can
simulate what is going to happen,
we can create an imaginary world where only
our creativity is the limit. For instance,
we can make a world in which there is just a
tiny bit of friction to slow down the fall.
Or, we can create a world
with a ton more friction,
and now, we have so much friction
going on that the weight of the liquid
cannot overcome anymore, and thus, the cube
is quickly brought to rest between the walls.
Luckily, since our bunny still exists, we can
proceed onto the next experiment, where we will
drop it onto a pile of granular material. This
previous method did not do too well in this case,
as the bunny sinks down. And if you think
that cannot possibly get any worse, well,
I have some news for you. It can. How? Look!
With a different previous technique, it doesn’t
even get to sink in, because it crashes when it
would need to perform these calculations. Now,
let’s see if the new method
can save the day, and…yes!
Great! It indeed can help our little
bunny remain on top of things.
So, let’s pop the Scholarly question -
how much do we wait for such a simulation?
The hourglass experiment takes
about 5 minutes per frame,
while the rotating drum experiment takes about
half of that, 2.5 minutes. So, it takes a while.
Why? Of course, because many of these scenes
contain tens of thousands of particles,
and almost all of them are in constant frictional
interaction with almost all the others at the
same time, and the algorithm mustn’t miss
any of these interactions. All of them
have to be simulated. And the fact that through
the power of computer graphics research we can
simulate all of these in reasonable amount of time
is an absolute miracle. What a time to be alive!
And as always, you know what’s coming. Yes, please
do not forget to invoke the First Law of Papers,
which says says that research is a
process. Do not look at where we are,
look at where we will be two more papers
down the line. Granular materials,
and frictional contact in a matter of seconds
perhaps? Well, sign me up for this one!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!